it's a bad start
good morning everybody officers and
councillors
welcome to the joint audit and standards
committee meeting of 17th of may
welcome to this joint audit and
standards committee i am councillor
brynn huron
and i am chairing the meeting today
may i first of all remind you of some
domestic arrangements
please ensure that you maintain social
distance from all
other persons in the chamber and in the
social areas
please ensure that you wear a mask
unless you are speaking
or if you're unable to do so that you
use the hand sanitizer of wipes provided
please maintain social distance at all
times during the meeting
and also during any breaks
please ensure that microphones are muted
when you are not
speaking and that you do not interrupt
other speakers
please switch off all mobile phones or
turn them to silent
that if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt
the meeting you may be asked to leave
additionally you will be invited to
speak and ask questions by the chair of
the meeting
and we will be using the e-voting system
for this meeting on modern gov
i would like to remind everybody present
that this meeting will be broadcast live
to the internet and will be capable of
repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be
recorded except where there are
confidential
or exempt items if you make a
representation to the meeting
you will be deemed by the council to
have consented to being recorded
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you are also consenting to being
recorded by
the council and to the possible use of
those sound recordings for webcasting
and or training purposes the council
members of the public and the press may
record
film photograph or broadcast this
meeting
when the public and the press are not
lawfully
excluded now i'll just make the
introductions of
the officers today we have an attendance
emily yeah who's the monitoring officer
and she is also deputizing for jon snell
today
catherine steele assistant director of
corporate resources
rebecca hurt assistant manager financial
accountant
yes i can see that mandy smith
governance officer
and also jan robinson behind me
i will now move to the agenda
can we have apologies for absence please
um yes chair we've received apologies
from uh
councillor mccraw um and councillor
fraser is not in attendance
okay thank you and we also have
apologies from john snell
and emily you will be answering
questions on his papers and presenting
them today
any declarations of pecuniary and
non-pecuniary interests by members
please
no thank you you can have confirmation
of the minutes of the meeting
of the 29th of march that was a virtual
meeting but
um we do have minutes for that and i
think i will be signing them today
are we all happy with the accuracy
please
proposer and seconder for that uh
dave muller and um oh god forgot your
name
yep thank you sorry
okay we now go to the vote on that so um
can we conduct the vote uh mandy please
thank you chair if um councillors could
go to the modern.gov app
um and that vote um
we'll be in progress when i start it
should now be in progress
just waiting for one more vote
um so um
counselor
lindsay would you like to give your vote
verbally yes sir
and councillor norris would you like to
give your vote verbally
thank you chair that's seven votes four
and one abstention
thank you mandy
now do we have any petitions
no none received thank you
questions by the public not received
questions by councillors non-received
thank you well we'll go straight into
jac 2019 the annual in
internal audit report 2021
and i think emily you're due to um
report on this please the floor is yours
thank you chairman and good morning
councillors and mayor say it's very nice
to see you all in person
um as the chairman's mentioned
unfortunately the corporate manager for
internal audit and data protection is
absent today so i am going to present
his report
and attempt to answer any questions that
you may have
so i do have his intro here so i will
read it out for you
the purpose of this report is to provide
counsellors with details of the work
undertaken by internal audit the year
202021
which is required under the public
sector internal audit standards
the report also details the review of
other corporate activities which are
supported by the work of the team
in line with the council's internal
audit charter the work has been
conducted
to ensure that it delivers against these
standards
and the requirement for john snell
corporate manager for internal audit and
data protection
to produce an annual internal audit
opinion at the end of the year
the team's work covers governance
processes monitoring arrangements
ethics information governance risk
management and fraud management
the work of internal audit is is
resourced from
internal staff and an external partner
reporting directly to the corporate
manager for internal order and data
protection
this arrangement allows a direct
internal provision
plus the benefits of commissioning
external skills and capacity
the option of working with an external
partner continues to be very effective
in that management retains control over
the internal audit function
while at the same time leveraging the
internal audit resource of the
party service provider it provides
access to valuable
and diverse specialized skills as needed
and achieves a level of flexibility
which can be critical in effectively
dealing with a range of operational
issues
moving to appendix a 90
of internal audit work completed during
20 2021
has yielded either a substantial or
sufficient or reasonable assurance
opinion over the design and operation of
the services systems and processes
audited
for the one audit review that was
assessed as having having
limited assurance actions have been
agreed with management to improve
controls
and are closely monitored until such a
time that they are addressed
this work is currently being followed up
and the results will be reported to this
committee in the midterm report
any outstanding weaknesses in the
governance risk and control framework
will continue to be followed up by
internal audit
full details of the audits completed are
reported in section 6.
due to the council's response to the
covert 19 emergency and
prioritization of workloads as
an impact has been felt on the internal
audit resource
and its ability to be to deliver normal
internal
internal audit work during the course of
the year
from april 2020 internal audit has and
continues to support the council's
tactical management team
responsible for managing emerging risks
and directing resources
to help ensure critical services are
maintained across the two districts
this includes and supporting the
business cell assisting with
checking emergency grant applications
for businesses
and more recently supporting the staff
matters cell
with responsibility for taking a
coordinated approach to different
factors affecting staff during the
pandemic
and looking at the preparation of
policies procedures and protocols
in addition the cell is responsible for
maintaining the redeployment list
and advising on requests made for
additional resources to the t
to support tmt decisions as a result
the corporate manager for internal audit
and data protection has agreed with
management
to defer a number of audits into 2021-22
and these are detailed in paragraph 6.3
of the report
as well as conducting internal audit
reviews
internal audit team has significant
involvement in a variety of other
council-wide activities
internal audit continue to perform well
against the agreed performance
indicators
audit clients continue to express a high
level of satisfaction with the service
delivered
and the latest figures are based on a 50
return
of the completed customer satisfaction
surveys
the reduced percentage of the order plan
delivered is as a result of
of responding to the covert 19 emergency
and resulting
reprioritization of workloads
and i will now read out the audit
opinion of the corporate manager which
is
is obviously the essential assurance
statement for this report
although the council's response to the
covered 19 emergency and
reprioritization of workloads
has had a significant impact on the
internal audit resource
and its ability to deliver normal audit
work during the course of the year
i am satisfied that sufficient assurance
work has been carried out to allow me to
form
a reasonable conclusion and an opinion
which is that
the council's framework of governance
risk management and internal control
provides sufficient reasonable assurance
the system process or activity should
achieve its objectives
safely and effectively however whilst
there are some control weaknesses
most key controls are in place and
operating effectively
where weaknesses have been identified
through internal audit review
internal audit have worked with
management to agree appropriate
corrective actions
and a time scale for improvement
in giving the the audit opinion it
should be noted that assurance can never
be
absolute the most that can be provided
is a reasonable assurance that there are
no major weaknesses
in risk management governance and
control processes
my opinion is based on written reports
on all internal audits completed
during the course of the year both
assurance and consultancy
results of any follow-up exercises
undertaken in respect of previous years
internal audit work
the results of work of other review
bodies where appropriate the extent of
resources
available to deliver the internal audit
work and
the impact of covert 19 and the approach
taken by management to the key
governance processes that enable
frontline services
to operate within a framework of control
there are no additional audit related
issues that currently need to be brought
to the attention of the committee
so chairman i'm happy to attempt to
answer any questions the committee
members may have
thank you
thank you emily um yeah this papers
i really enjoyed reading this it does
really show what we're all about i think
and
checking and being upfront um
i just wondered emily this must have
been a nightmare to do this in a virtual
way
because all this has been carried out
during lockdown hasn't it
any comment on that and just also the
ones we've had to defer for
obvious capacity reasons will they be
first
back for a light touch audit or will
they just be worked in with everything
else
do you know that yes sure so in respect
of the the first part um as with all
teams in the council the internal audit
team has adapted very quickly and
efficiently to a virtual
system of working and in my view it
hasn't had any
um adverse impact on on the quality of
the
internal um audits that have been
undertaken
and actually it's a credit to our
systems that we have set up that we've
been able to access those systems and do
those reviews in in a virtual way
um in terms of the deferred audits
they have been included in the internal
audit plan for 2122
and they followed the usual pattern of
risk assessment that
um john undertakes when he allocates
prioritization of audits so
he's um he will have assessed them based
on
um their level of risk to the
organization and their level of urgency
given that they've been deferred and
then
he's waving them into the plan
accordingly
okay thank you emily for that it's a
shame that john isn't here today but i'm
sure we all
ambush him well um any questions
comments from members
please council
um miller a quick question emily thank
you very much and again
thank you very much to all the members
of the audit team for the work they've
done this year
we're really impressed with the work
it's just basically on page 24 of our
papers
uh 6.1.4 assets and investments
asset management it's obviously work in
progress
can i have assurance that that work will
be completed in the current
financial year please
yes chair i can confirm that that will
be completed in in this next municipal
year
thank you very much thank you that's all
thank you
now is the extent of
external support um can you hazard a and
guess
of how much um what proportion
of the work of the um is it 2021 year
has been carried out by external support
rather than by our own
staff
chair i don't have the exact figures on
on that proportion
however i do i can hazard a guess
that it was less than 50 um
due to the pandemic and and due to those
deferred audits
so a lot of the work actually undertaken
was was by
internal staff um during the last
financial year
however the external partner is very
much geared up to take on some of those
key audits in
the um forthcoming years uh internal
audit plan
and we're really looking forward to
working working with them on those
audits
uh just in terms of the work that they
did undertake
we've had some really positive feedback
from the various different service areas
that have worked with
the external provider um and we're
finding that it's it's been seamless so
almost the experience of using the extra
or being audited by the external partner
is
is no different than being audited by
one of our internal members of staff
thank you yeah thank you i mean
i can see the the usefulness of external
support for specialist
areas um i mean as it's it's your
um you know your management
responsibility or part of
um i mean what what do you think is is a
um
a satisfactory proportion
that we should that we should aim for
um obviously i'm
you know in previous meetings i've
expressed some concern about
um you know continuity arrangements
essentially
since mr jarvis left particularly
and yeah whether whether we're actually
actively
recruiting at the moment thank you
uh so i i don't want to misquote the
internal audit plan for 2122 because i
know john has included the distribution
of hours in there
and the split between internal audit and
and external
but i would ex i would expect that to be
at least a 50 50 split if not
more uh more heavily weighted towards
the external provider
and given that they've got such a spread
of resource that we can tap
into we aren't actively recruiting
people to the internal audit team we've
made a decision that the external
partner is the way to provide
internal order at least for the next 12
months but we do keep that under
continual review john is our contract
manager in terms of that
relationship with the external provider
he has regular meetings with
with their leadership and i'm sure if
the committee
wished that the external provider would
be willing to to
have somebody come along and talk to you
about about their business and their
operation if that would help
to give the committee some reassurance
that the model does work very very well
yeah just developing that subject emily
i i think maybe john is worrying there's
a cost implication
um it's obviously more expensive the
outside partner isn't it
is that a fair comment um actually
chairman
it's more cost effective to use the
outside partner so we have we do
actually
um have achieved us or we have actually
achieved a saving
through that contract um this this
provider is
very used to working with public sector
clients and we've managed to achieve a
very very competitive rate
with them which they have uh maintained
at the same level
for this year's contract as well so it
is a it's a
it's a very beneficial contract both in
terms of the financial aspect but also
in terms of the
skills and resilience it brings to the
internal audit function
thank you it's a win-win then john
council mclaren thank you thank you
chair
i add my good wishes to jon snell as
well
it's a shame he's not here today uh
chair i don't
sorry can you is that better
and i don't even have to put my hand up
do i yellow hand but
um i i don't want to ask a question i
just want to pay tribute
to well the overall report is excellent
and i enjoyed reading it like
you but i think the team that stood out
for me and
i don't particularly want to pick out a
particular team
we're the grants team in the report
when we think that um
everybody was remote working there was a
diversity of grants that were being
changed routinely by the treasury
i think that team given that there was
three mistakes in the in the report i
think well done to them for a job that
was
excellent thank you
well i think we'd all echo that um i
remember when this first happened things
uh flying past my desk and um you could
tell
how hard they were working and even
getting things out to local members to
try and contact people it was um
it was quite brilliant i think that can
be minuted can't it and um
um congratulations can be passed on well
deserved
counseling
thank you chairman um
on there's just one thing on housing
health and safety
in the table there it says a limited
assurance
to be followed up early next year um
and there's a whole there's three
different areas where
you know the potential risks lie have
been
helpfully highlighted there um but i
just wonder if
you know that where if there's a sense
of if we can get a
better sense of what's going on there
and
it says recommendations have been made
to further strengthen governance and
oversight
um do you have any sense of that
that there is a risk of things going
wrong in
health and safety in housing
yes thank you councillor lindsay i think
when i read it i wasn't sure whether
we're worried about the
um tenants or the um staff but i'm sure
emily can
enlighten us on that
yes thank you i do have an update from
um the assistant director for housing
um who has said that there has been a
comprehensive
over overview of the work done to date
against an action plan
and that's been presented to the health
and safety board so
the health and safety board is
monitoring um and
overseeing uh the the actions that have
been agreed by management in response to
that audit opinion
um they also have the external partner
tia currently
conducting a follow-up review of
progress since the original
recommendations were made so
there is very clear activity there to
ensure that those
concerns are addressed and an action
plan in place and it's being monitored
um
i think chair just just regards to your
comment i
my understanding is that the health and
safety concerns were about
safe systems of work rather than any
risk to our tenants
okay thank you
you're happy for that okay any other
questions
appetite into this paper
everybody happy well done
yep very very good um paper emily i'm
sorry that you're thrown in at the deep
end of it but um
obviously we've all read it and um uh
extremely happy with it to know that
these sort of safety checks are going on
now that doesn't need to be voted upon
does it this one
it does need a vote no okay
so straight on to item eight
joint annual governance statement um
and that'll be you again emily i'm
afraid
thank you
oh i see no well no i didn't ask for any
um
questions or comments so um
there were none i don't think we're all
done yes everyone
put thumbs up and to be done okay we'll
quickly move to the vote on that one my
apologies
thank you chair say item seven i'll open
the vote on modern.gov
if you'd like to go to the app that
should now be showing in progress
counselor lindsay can i take your vote
thank you
take a chair that's unanimously for
thank you mandy i'm sorry for the
confusion it's a little difficult to
hear you when you're masked up
right okay item mate sorry that
everybody
join annual government statement and
that will be you again emily please
thank you chairman and again i've got an
introduction from
the corporate manager to read out for
you
this report reviews each council's
corporate governance arrangements during
2020-21
as required by the accounts and audit
regulations 2015
and is presented as a joint statement to
reflect the government
governance arrangements in place across
both councils
it provides an insight looking ahead for
this year and the key challenges facing
both councils moving forward
as well as addressing those challenges
identified during 2019-20
and the actions taken this committee has
responsibility for being satisfied that
the statement properly reflects the
governance arrangements in place
baba and suffolk have adopted a local
code of corporate governance
that sets out a commitment to corporate
governance and summarizes the
government's
governance arrangements and activities
in place to which is
it is accountable and engages with its
communities
the local code is consistent with the
principles of the sit for solace
framework
known as delivering good governance in
local gov in local government
this statement explains how the councils
have complied with the local code and
have met the requirements of the
accounts and audit regulations 2015.
to reflect the code the ags includes
assurance statements from various
offices representing the oversight
functions
as well as the annual audit opinion from
the corporate manager internal audit and
data protection
the senior leadership team have also had
the opportunity to view and comment on
the ags as part of the review process
the ags provides an assurance of the
effectiveness of the council system of
internal controls
the arrangements continue to be regarded
as fit for purpose in accordance with
the governance framework
there have been no governance issues
identified during the year that are
considered significant
in relation to each council's overall
governance framework
the covered 19 emergency has meant that
the councils have had to make a number
of changes to
their governance arrangements this
governance
statement provides assurance that the
government's governance
arrangements that have been in place
during 2020-21
were sufficient and robust and it also
identifies through the assurance
statements from officers
the issues and changes that have been
implemented in response to the emergency
while assessing the impact of covert 19
it has given us the opportunity for both
councils to look
to transform how we deliver our services
by reviewing
remodeling and reinventing the way the
councils operate to provide better
services to our customers
increase social value reduce our costs
and without compromising services
to look to genera to increase and
generate income
chairman i am happy to attempt to answer
any questions that the committee
may have thank you
thank you emily just one from the
chair i think really when you read this
it's about everything that we do um i
tend to think of orders just about
financial things but this
is also about um the way we lead people
and everything else
environmental things and planning
decisions
is that correct is it yes chair the
um the annual governance statement is
comprehensive looking at all of the
processes and systems that the
the council delivers and and thereby all
of the services that are
involved which is why you'll see a range
of different officers providing
assurance statements within within the
statement itself
yeah i just raised that casually because
sometimes
um when we do things we sometimes make
people quite unhappy because of
decisions we have to take and it's a bit
of a
struggle to sort of compromise what we
do at all times isn't it but that's just
a general point just to make members
aware that
um it's not always possible to please
everybody
all of the time which is why we're
elected isn't it
uh questions please or
any comments council mclaren
thank you chair um i just want to rela i
hope
emily perhaps knows the answer to this
but i just want to refer to page 47 of
the
report and the middle of that it talks
about
the scope for improvement and one of
those areas was the
community infrastructure levy
and i just wondered if there was any
expansion on that
sort of statement if there was i was
going to ask john if
he could explain probably what was the
problem with that
thank you
chair i i'm afraid i don't have the
detail to answer that question but i i
will take it away and ask john
for an explanation thank you emily i
would appreciate that thank you
comment if i may please um can i thank
um
all the officers for this report it's an
absolutely excellent report
very good reading and i'm really
impressed with the amount of work that's
gone into that bearing in mind all the
extra work that officer have
with dealing with the pandemic etcetera
and i would really like that recorded in
the minutes
thank you very much anyway to everyone
involved with that thank you thank you
yes i think that's endorsed from the
chair as well emily it does
when you read it look at it in depth it
does encompass everything we do as i
already said
so um good paper uh councilor matheson
please
thank you chair yes the the um
some comments really i i um
obviously i've read a number of these
over over the years and
you know i think the the first one
i i really i really struggled with um
i mean it is a it's a statement of how
we
we should be running the council
and at that time i i was able to see a
number of points in which we were not
doing what it said
in the statement um but that was under a
previous chief executive and a previous
monitoring officer and
i i am quite confident that things are
um much better now um i think that the
one area that i'm
about how how our governance works
not that we we're doing we're not doing
what we're supposed to be
doing but more that the the removal
of um portfolio reports
from full council to
um to cabinets and the
the fact that cabinet questions are
restricted to um
items that are on on the agenda of the
cabinet and so on
um i'm afraid i do experience that as
a somewhat of a loss of accountability
and and i i do you know i do feel
that this is the right point to make
that um
observation actually um but
as as to doing what it says in the
report um
you know by my feeling is that yes yes
we are
um so it's um
that's whether that requires any
amendment uh to the report i don't know
thank you councillor matheson i'm good
to know we're improving obviously all
down to your hard work
um any comment on the um council cabinet
um
uh comment emily
um chair only to to clarify that um
there was a full review of the
constitution
uh two two years ago now i believe which
was a cross-party
um constitution working group and
obviously adopted by
both councils so um the provisions in
there have been developed
very much with with councillors um but
of course there's always opportunity to
review the
the provisions of the constitution and
if
the the question of the question of
questions to cabinet
is something that uh members would like
to be reviewed then we can do that as
part of our ongoing um
review of the constitution and just in
terms of cabinet
member reports um that was agreed the
the approach to cabinet member reporting
was agreed
with the leader of the council and the
leader of the green and liberal democrat
group so
um that that is a uh a united or
um comprehensive um decision to
to deal with them in that way
are you happy with that counselor
matheson you can always attend the
cabinet as
as well as you know yes uh yes i i do
know
um i mean i think that the to say that
the leader of our group was entirely
happy with with the with the outcomes is
um yeah stretching things a bit frankly
um but um we'll um we'll look for
another review another day
thank you
okay thank you any other questions or
comments on this paper
uh council casting thank you
thank you chairman yeah i'd just like to
echo councillor muller
in saying that this is this is a really
good
uh it's a big piece of work
it's it's clear there's a lot of detail
in there and it does
it does take some reading but the the
the report is a very complicated
very um in-depth look at what we do
and and how it works but um yeah
fantastic piece of work
and i'm really really pleased with it
and
under circumstances that weren't
absolutely um
straightforward and there was a lot of
them there there was a lot of how we're
going to do this now
and we're going on a year ago um so
um yeah i'd like to say well done to the
team and um
thank you very much and i think this
would
will be useful to every councillor
really to um
look at and just just to check on
what's going on and reinforce you know
that
that information that they know already
yeah
thank you
thank you um yes absolutely it should be
compulsory reading for all councils i've
read it twice and
made lots of marks and highlights and
was very impressed
um it's down to resources but obviously
if we do everything we say in here
we'll be doing pretty well and everybody
should be happy but as i said earlier
it's um
it's a difficult ground isn't it any
other comments or any debate
needed any other questions
nope okay but we definitely need a vote
on this one so
over to you mandy thank you chair so
members if you go to the model.gov app
this vote should now be in progress
counselor lindsay can i take your vote
thank you
i'm coming a little bit difficult to do
two things at once
nearly there
would you like me to take your vote
verbally chair no i'm coming
okay
oh i'm four yeah i've come on the wrong
one mandy but i'm four
four actually unanimously for them
okay item nine everybody this is
probably the um
main grist of the meeting today
environmental social and governance
considerations for the council joint
treasury management
and i think rebecca you're going to um
lead us on this one um
good morning i thought i spotted you
behind the trendy mask
thank you chair good morning councillors
um this report
presents the key considerations for
developing an environmental
social governance policy for the
council's treasury management
investments
in order to facilitate discussion on the
preferred way forward
it considers how an esg policy could
incorporate
environmental considerations into the
council's investment decisions
to reflect the ambition to make suffolk
carbon neutral by 2030
the main focus for addressing climate
change is investment in fossil fuels
there are two main approaches to
addressing fossil fuels to engage or to
exclude
also known as screening if a screening
approach is taken
it would need to be considered whether
exclusions apply only to extractors and
producers
or whether it extends further in the
value chain such as end-of-chain sellers
including supermarkets
alternatively investors can choose to
engage
one view is that investors should shift
their focus more to supporting companies
that are helping the transition to net
zero
and using their ownership clout to force
change at transgressors
rather than screening out the climate
problem from their portfolios
the un principles of responsible
investment provides a framework against
which fund managers can be assessed for
their approach to esg
the councils are each invested in four
strategic pooled funds
which were entered into with the key
objective of generating revenue income
each of these fund managers is a
signatory to the un
principles of responsible investment
framework and scores well against it
the report sets out the approach to esg
for each of the council's four strategic
funds
the council's treasury management
advisor arlene close has advised that
where
that there are equity funds with income
strategies that screen out fossil fuel
extractors
or whose focus is on renewable energy
and or decarbonization
however the yield for these ranges
between 0.5
to 3.3 percent compared to an average of
5.2 percent for the council's existing
funds
although the total overall return for
each of the council's existing
funds since investment has been positive
they have incurred
unrealised capital losses as shown in
paragraph 4.38 of the report
if these funds are redeemed to invest in
esg funds
the unrealized losses would need to be
recognised as a revenue cost
this report is presented to members to
facilitate discussion on the preferred
approach
the following points should be
considered when considering developing
an esg policy
firstly the council's key objective in
holding strategic board funds
which was to generate a source of
revenue income for the councils
secondly the difference in yield for esg
funds and what an acceptable cost would
be to move
to esg funds thirdly the cost of the
redemption of the council's existing
funds
then whether to exclude fossil fuels or
focus on funds that engage well with
companies in the fossil fuel industry
and also finally how the council's
existing investments score against the
pri framework
and whether any of these should be
retained
we'll be happy to answer any questions
you have on this report
right thank you rebecca um
there's no definite recommendations um
on this paper only it's down to us
to start the ball rolling so um i think
we need to set um
the pathway ourselves in conjunction
with officers
councilor matheson thank you yeah could
you just run over the fifth
of the of those points that we needed to
consider again i didn't quite get that
one
yes certainly um so the final
consideration was how the council's
existing
investment funds score against the the
framework from the principles of
responsible investment
and also whether any of the existing
funds of the council should be retained
on that basis
hi thank you just just to ask we're
going to do questions now
are we also going to go to debate or
well i think we'll ask questions on the
paper first and any comments and then
the
debate will follow i would imagine yeah
okay
thank you uh councillor lindsey
yeah thanks chad um the um
there's a lot of um comments about the
fund managers
being a plus or a for
pri
has that how does that relate to
actually the carbon intensity of their
investments and the
the you know that i presume that doesn't
that isn't a measure of how much how
many fossil fuel assets
they own
but just checking yeah yes that's
correct so
it doesn't relate to how many fossil
fuels
they hold it's more relating to how they
disclose
their activity on how they engage with
fossil fuel companies and other
other companies
it's very differentiate between the two
isn't it but um we all clear on the
paper
yep well let's open the debate then
far away councilor matheson
yeah i i think the the first thing that
struck me really was that
um on the 425 and council linda's just
just alluded to that
this is these um sort of
scoring against the united nations i've
forgot what pr
pri is now but um anyway this sort of
scoring system and and
well you know they're all all very very
good
um and and the the problem is
they they don't actually offer much
much of a basis for just distinguishing
different ones
and i remembered the um
experience years ago that i i bought the
state-of-the-art freezer 15 years ago
and it was an a plus
energy rating i thought fantastic and
actually now they're all they're all a
or a plus but if you want a really
really good one it's a plus plus plus
and and so really what happened was that
the the whole
energy rating system that was brought in
15 years ago
um was sort of overtaken by by
technology improvements
which is great however um
i think the same sort of problem arises
here
that that everything that we're
investing with is
is a of one kind or another most of it
is a plus
and um so so it's it's difficult and
perhaps there's some extent this comes
back to to what council lindsey
said um the the
the the pri framework
is is subsumes a lot of different
factors into into
its assessment to come up with a plus
and we we need to kind of understand
quite a bit more
particularly if our greatest concern is
actually
one of the three components of the
environmental
component more than the social and
and governance one which are um
generally taken care of reasonably well
in most
of the larger companies that these sort
of investments are
are with so um that's
that's a sort of the initial kind of
problem
i think with the um
with what we've got in front of us at
the moment that um you know i'd want to
kind of winkle out a little bit more
um before getting to a complete
view about it or listen to what others
have got to say now
thank you i think what you're saying
counselor matheson is the indicators are
are moving as well aren't you the um
goal posts are changing
it is drifting that way anyway which is
my feeling
yeah well i mean
that suggests that the same thing is
happening that esg performance
generally is improving i suppose what
um what particular concern you know my
particular concern
would be um that the environmental
component is not moving fast enough
uh compared to um the
you know united nations goals for on
tackling climate change which suggests
we've got to move very fast
and um so yeah the general drift is
welcome but on the other hand
um you know the reason why uh
certainly iron and others have pressed
for this report to come
here is particularly on that specific
area
so i know whether rebecca or officers
can help us
with that very much welcome to here
i think the choice here councillor
matthing is do we go with the flow or do
we want to do more which is
part of the reason that we're um here
today um councillor casten
thank you very much mr chairman um yeah
i'd
i did do a bit of winkling as some the
council
said or i believe you said um
and um these investment funds i don't
have a huge issue
with these funds from a um environmental
point of view the
the one the schroeder fund
for me is um is the one that we
would maybe focus in on with this report
they um
they have um investments in
um shell and bp and also
imperial uh tobacco um company and
they're quite large holdings um
you know sort of four or five percent
but
i really want to
like discuss what we're trying to
achieve with this because these funds
are a collection of lots of other funds
the money's spread out right through
them we know we'll get
a better income off these
we can use that income to do
absolutely tangible things within our um
our district to improve the um
environment to reduce our carbon the um
something like schroder with its um with
those take those three holdings for
instance
you've got tobacco people who always
want again to want to buy tobacco
um imperial um will
always be able to sell tobacco they're
looking at water shortages and
making it more sustainable to
grow tobacco which other people's
people might not people are still going
to buy that tobacco cars are still going
to need fuel
for the moment bp
uh michelle and these companies have got
infrastructure they've got
stations on you know in very convenient
places
so as soon as the rollout of something
better and we will go for it because
cars
cars are going to be phased out we've
got a date when they
we won't have internal you know fossil
fuel cars anymore
um these positions
are going to be crucial in the
green hydrogen revolution and all these
things
are we saying we don't invest in them
because
another company will come along and get
infrastructure in those places
so that um we can do we can we can carry
on with this um revolution
um i'm not really quite sure what we
achieved by that um
i personally would prefer to have the
money
and be able to use that in our in our
district
to set an example and reduce our carbon
and teach children the importance of
this
the um no one in bp
is going to um worry that
this small amount of um
of of this some fund is taken out it
goes into a fund where there's several
ones i understand that if everyone does
it yes it does make a difference but
the the more investment there is the
more they can do the more technology
moves on
and the more we get away out of this
fossil fuel
hole that we're in so
personally i think i'm i'm not i'm not
for this
i've listened to debate but i i don't
think this makes enough difference and i
think that money to this um council
makes a huge difference especially with
how the council
is looking at this environment situation
and what the work we've done already um
but
yeah i'm quite happy to listen to other
councillors and i'm sure there's some
very good points
um i must admit i do actually agree with
my colleague
councillor casten but i also think it's
important what's mentioned in paragraph
4.14
on page 80 that divesting fossil fuel
investments may not be the most cost
effective solution
to combat climate change so i think we
have to look at this very very carefully
and i think all the comments that we
made by other colleagues as well are
also very important
but we don't want to end up losing funds
that really are desperately needed for
for the council
and i think that's got to be our
priority is obviously yes we must ignore
climate change
it is an emergency it's very very
important
but at the end of the day we don't want
to divest lose money
at this moment in time thank you
thank you um yeah i mean
arguably good points um
however maybe i can offer an alternative
context to
um what you appear to be operating in
and i wonder
um how aware we are
of the shifting nature of the financial
landscape
that that we're operating in and
the risk the financial risk that we
might be
exposing ourselves to by by taking a
more
conservative approach little c um
to to our investment strategy so i want
to read just this
key paragraph from a
corporate
statement document by a one particular
think tank which says
adoption of solar wind and battery
is growing exponentially worldwide and
disruption
is now inevitable because by 2030
they will offer the cheapest electricity
option for most regions
coal gas and nuclear assets will become
stranded
during the uh 2020s
and no new investment in these
technologies is rational from this point
forward
that's what one leading like think tank
is saying so
you know i don't have all the answers i
don't know how how
much truth to put in that but as part of
the information that's available to us
it's something to consider right so
thank you counselor amazon um i can tell
you would like to push for change
um councillor lindsay please
thank you chip thank you chair um
so we as a council whether was it a year
ago
said that um we declared a climate
emergency
and said that this was one of the most
important things i think
i think everyone's agreed on that
reducing carbon
[Music]
but that doesn't really if if we're
talking about
we need to reduce carbon emissions
as a council people are going to look at
us
wonder why it stops outside
our doors why we carry on investing
in campaigns like bp and shell
if we're doing all all the officers and
the council and sales doing all we can
to cut our own direct emissions and yet
we're putting our money into fossil fuel
um so i think
an answer to the council of casters
question do oh there won't be where bp
won't be worried by us removing our tiny
amount
um actually they will be
because all councils
have a bit of money in companies like bp
and shell
they're very scared the president
i think it's slightly naive to assume
that these companies
their business plan is to extract
fossil fuel and sell it now i know
there's a lot of detail here from the
fund managers
about how they've been talking to these
firms over years
and the firms have promised them this
and that they're going to reduce
production by x
amount a lot of that is because they
have to reduce production
because demand has fallen because of the
growth in renewable
uh we're facing they're facing a
shrinking
dwindling market and their value is
shrinking
all the time and this is what counselor
morrison was referring to with
the risk of stranded assets and new
businesses are coming in
um if you look at the field of electric
cars completely
you know the car industry the
conventional car industry could be wiped
out
by um by electric car makers
uh the same with the energy industry
could happen
these these companies are clinging on to
their business plan
which means because they own billions of
pounds
of assets of fossil fuel assets they're
not going to tear up that business plan
just because they've had engagement from
a few fund managers
they will they will want to sell as much
of those assets as we can
and all the science tells us that we
can't go on
uh extracting and burning fossil fuel we
have to stop
we have to reduce it to zero and our own
council
says has said we're going for a
zero by 2030. so to carry on blindly
investing in these companies and the
naive hope that they will somehow change
their ways
by 2030 is is wrong course i suggest
thank you
thank you um councillor lindsay also in
the last paper we did acknowledge that
we would be um
trying to do something about the climate
emergency um so we are signed up to that
can i just bring the officers in um
[Music]
catherine rebecca is there a way we can
give a big nudge
to some of the people we invest in or
gradual change what is your professional
view
catherine probably on this one i think
we do need to
um make a marker here and
ask for change and even give a more than
a hefty nudge that would be my view
what do you think can we do that
thank you chair um i suppose all things
are are possible
um but really the paper today was to
spark some debate to discussion
to get an idea of where you know
the committee are thinking they would
like to go with it
and ultimately it's probably going to be
a cabinet decision
around a policy like this so
it's all what really you want to
recommend you know there are there are
consequences
um from my point of view as a section
151 officer you can see in the report at
the moment there is a capital
cost at the moment because the assets
are valued below
so i think at the moment we we would be
foolish in terms of finances to divest
while we're below the capital value but
it would be good to know
what um you wanted it to look like when
we've got to that position and we could
make some some choices
in terms of where the money was so for
example you know if there was a decision
about fossil fuels then
if at the point we can take money out of
schroders then we can look at funds
that would have that ex you know not in
it as for example
um so i think you know because of where
we're at with the capital value i don't
think we can do
some immediate things but it would be
really good to have a framework in place
that we can
work to as the opportunities come along
so if that helps a committee ah thank
you
that's exactly what i was looking for
you know i'm mindful reading this that
our investments bring us in
over 400 000 plus don't they
and you're saying that because they're
valued low
because of whatever reason they might
climb back and be worth more
anyway and they certainly have been the
last few months
the value has been coming back up and i
think it was 91
we're almost just about at the point you
know where
where we invested the money in the first
place so they are coming back
up to that point and the value and and
there is also a choice obviously for the
council i mean there's been various
views about the income that we get and
what we do with it
there would be a reduction in the income
so again that's a choice
but we know that choice has already been
made by the council i'm just looking at
the the hbo
fuel for example you know that had a
cost attached to it
and both councils have decided to go
ahead with that so
really looking for a steer you know as
to what committee
would like to to recommend potentially
okay thank you catherine that's helpful
several hands up now i
i think i saw yours first robert but
whoever at the back thank you chair so
it's not easy is it it's a
controversial subject um and i don't
want to dominate things i've
i've only spoken once in the debate so
far um
only to just slightly
question this idea that because
i mean i sit on the pension committee at
county council
the last thing in the world you look at
when you're deciding what
how to allocate your investments is what
it was worth when you bought it
because that that's not really a valid
trading strategy
you you look at the future
profits so there may be other things
that we can invest in
that give us a better return um
i i don't i don't quite follow because
it's below it's
a few years ago we invested in it and
the capital value has fallen
to you know any any financial advisor
would say
with your own investment don't look at
the don't look at what you bought it for
because it may never recover
they never recover and we'll be hanging
on forever as the
as the value goes up and down and slowly
goes
further and further down um and it may
be that they've fallen because
they're heavily into uh fossil fuel
assets i don't know
but i i don't quite follow this this
line argument that
we can't divest simply because
the assets are worth less than what we
bought them for some time ago
it's the it's the income we get and the
future returns that matter
yes thank you um council lindsay
catherine can you clear that up because
i i
that was going to be my question as well
obviously you're saying we're earning an
income and it's getting worth more is
that correct
and and and the 64 000 question will
this continue
or as people turn away will it then
slump more i think that's what's
generally being asked
again again it's a choice um and a
choice that
that is done in you know knowing all the
facts so i mean at the moment you've got
the table in 438
so you can see what the the current you
know
valuations are of the funds as at 31st
march
so that would be a cost so just taking
the schroeder's one as an example you
know it's
almost half a million pounds down so if
we
um divested from that we would get
roughly one and a half million pounds
back from our two million
and we'd only have one and a half
million that we could invest in
something else
because that cost is a real cost to the
council
we can't then say we're going to invest
another 2 million if the cash isn't
isn't available so again there are there
are choices to be made
um in terms of again what is the the
acceptable cost
to the council to to move the funds
but clarify from my point not all that 2
million is invested in
fossil fuel um companies is it it's it's
spread anyway so
something else is going down as well it
is spread but obviously we just
invest in that fund so so the schroders
fund if you buy units in that fund
i don't believe them rebecca might
correct me if i'm wrong i don't believe
you can say
i want units in this fund but i don't
want them to be in fossil fuel
i think you have to then look for
another fund that doesn't invest in
fossil fuels
do you want to clarify that rebecca are
you happy with what's been said
yeah that's i'm happy with what's been
said that's my understanding as well
okay
yes thank you um
i think the report has been very useful
um
in actually drawing out um
why officers were reluctant to and
obviously we began to discuss this back
in in january
um why why there was the great
reluctance
um and and it turned you know it turns
out that the
if if our accounts were being done you
know council accounts were being run on
the same basis
as as um a company outside a private
company
um then the the that loss
that's been identified that specific
loss
um would would have to be accounted for
each year and we would show
a loss or if if the value had gone up we
would show again
each year but it so happens that the
government
decided and and i i reference up the
is now my reference up there's a
paragraph that it actually explains this
specifically um the government has said
that the
councils can not do that
for for the next two or three years
um but we'll have to do it in 2023 24 i
think
is yeah katherine's nodding um
so at the moment we we have this loss
but we're not declaring it um
we're not we're not going to suffer
we're not going to have to take that
amount of money
out of what we could what we've got
available to spend
we're going to say well at the bottom of
the accounts at the end of the year
the revaluation of the schroders and the
other funds
resulted in a loss of x um
which indeed is what happens with with
the cifco accounts
and then those are brought forward into
enter into the council's accounts in
that way
and um yes
the overall fund has been going down
recently but there's been some very
turbulent
times for businesses generally so it's
not very surprising
um so i think and now i'll come back to
what
council lindsay has said is is that the
what matters is if we
sell the schroders and buy something
which is esg filtered
and has not got fossil fuels in it
for the amount of money that we get at
the moment
will that fund that that's filtered will
that go
up roughly
the same as the rest of the market
or will it will it perform better
than if we stayed with the schroder one
that we have
or will it perform worse and and
in capital terms that's that's the
question
if you like now there's a separate
question and i understand what council
kassadin has said
um that the currently the
the income of the dividends and the
interest
and the rents to are less
on on the the esg filtered fund
and and that would be a real loss that
we would suffer
um but that
in the short term that that is a cost of
of doing the right thing
and and pursuing our our corporate
policy
which is to to actually try and
do our contribution to tackling climate
change that can get to zero
co2 emissions by 2030 and and so that's
real money
and the other stuff is not real money
it's just
accounting entries and it's it's just
the same
as when councillor whitehead gets up our
finance portfolio and no doubt the same
thing
in weber and says well if the the
pacifico loss is not real money
it's only accounting it doesn't matter
etc etc and it's just the same as that
actually
so you know i think that it's perfectly
reasonable
to say we should make some moves at the
moment the cabinet should decide to make
some moves at the moment
and and that if we can go
if we can find something
amongst you know other possible
investments
that that um has and i i think i come
back to
that we strike a different balance
between income and and risk
and that if we we could perhaps achieve
the same level of income as we are at
the moment
by running a greater degree of risk and
that greater degree of risk
would go where council amoroson has as
pointed
which is is that it would it would
invest
more directly in in the businesses
that we think all the the experts and
the fund managers think
are going to be the future
in in a carbon reducing and carbon free
world so
that's that that to me that is my
statement of
the the choice one part of it doesn't
actually matter
the other part does matter and it's a
judgement
and we should we should grasp that
thank you councillor matheson i don't
think it's in our gift to um
make a decision but we can send a strong
stare to cabinet and council i would
imagine
councillor castin
thank you very much mr chairman um
the council lindsay um does obviously
have experience of investments and um
it's um i do agree with them that if
investments are losing money you got to
sell them what at whatever time they
need to be sold
but i will say that this this this is
not a normal event these aren't
um this the book cost isn't losing money
at the moment
it's um round about the end of february
2020
we had a black swan event on the stock
market
everything dropped um dropped a long way
the um so we valued these
funds on the 31st of march
in the latest valuations of those the
us ubs has gone up 1.55
that's um that's given that's increased
its book cost
of around twenty three thousand pounds
the um this the um schroeder
since the 31st of march has gone up 3.31
um it's still got a long way to go but
that's about
51 000 pounds it's increased since the
31st
of march and the 91
investment is now in positive
um the value it's some it's worth
around 15 000 pounds more than we bought
it for
so this is what is happening in the
stock market in these funds at the
moment
they've hit a real low because of corona
virus
things are recovering they're good solid
sound investments these people know
exactly what they're doing
um you know we we can talk about ethics
but these
these people absolutely know what
they're doing that's why people put so
much faith
and put money into these investments we
need to
definitely give them a chance to recover
before
we um before we cash that in these
funds are a long term you've got you've
got to do them long term they don't
they they don't work if you trade them
like shares and i just think
we've we've got to definitely not think
of these
as losing money they're they're
recovering
slowly but they're they're slowly
recovering and
i don't see any reason why they won't
reach
what they were pre pandemic and um
you know and improve on that the um
their
their income shares the um
the yes the the book cost is evaluation
and it's a really important valuation
because that's money you haven't got if
you sold them today
but if you're not selling today that
makes a massive difference to how we
look at these investments and how we
look at the income
coming in from them so i i do argue the
fact that
it's time to get out because i don't
think it is but obviously i can't
predict the future if i am
if i if i knew these things i i wouldn't
be sat here i'd be
um i'd be in an office in london but
um that's that's my view on it anyway
my layperson view thank you council okay
can you just put your microphone up
please thank you i think we should all
remind ourselves that councils don't
move quick do they
and i think catherine would agree with
that if we make a recommendation the
time it gets anywhere near a decision
will probably be six or nine months so i
think it's reasonable catherine to say
that maybe
at that time it might be time to look at
it a bit more closely that would be my
view if it's going in the right way by
the time we get round to making a
decision
um it could be time then to look at it
and
seize the moment but um you know i would
impress upon you all
nothing's going to happen quickly it
never does we're not private individuals
the wheels of local government creak
pretty slowly
councillor mclaren thank you chair
yes i was interested that um catherine
had brought this to the table for
discussion and i think that
i'm not as knowledgeable as my
colleagues
[Music]
and it has clarified a lot of things for
me
but i as somebody that does do
ethical investments they dropped
considerably
last year and they're on the way
back and one of the things that in
investments
is that you've got to hold your nerve
when things are changing
and not dramatically overreact
but i think as a council we should and
as a committee
we should be moving forward so i'm all
for us moving forward
in an ethical direction i'm all for that
but i think
to make reactive judgments on what we've
got in front of us
considering the terrible time
across the world for economics and for
investments
i think now is the wrong time to make
any
strong decisions
i think if we think now by the time we
um are ready the time might be right
anyway it might coincide um
council ramblers
so just to maybe reframe
the discussion we're talking in terms of
at the moment in terms of uh divesting
and
and ethics and you know biting the
bullet and
sort of casting this transition in a
negative
light when actually this could be
like a huge opportunity to the
the flip side of this of this waiting
for our current funds to
um increase is that the longer we delay
the the the more that we're missing out
on and the big
as we know i appreciate your sort of
focus on the detail um cancel the
casting
and um and uh
but however we know that the big the big
picture if we if we just zoom out
is that you know those fossil fuel funds
are sun setting it's a sun setting
industry
and the sunrise industry is his
renewables
and so the the longer we
delay the the more we're we're not just
waiting for these incremental increases
from our existing funds but the longer
we delay where
we're missing out on getting in at
a lower level with the with the newer
um ethical funds
and we're we're missing out on that
exponential curve where
we know that this decade is going to be
it's going to be exponential for
renewables
so the sooner we can get in at that
ground level which will probably already
like
not you know it's it's we
we've known for a long time so we're all
ready like you're not at the growing
level but
the sooner we can get there then um
potentially just to reframe the
conversation there's an opportunity it's
not about
it's not about shooting ourselves in the
foot yeah
thank you anyone else wishing to speak
anything to add to the debates
robert i will allow you to speak a third
time
i appreciate it chairman um i'm trying
to
i'm trying to be constructive here um to
find a way through the
half um i just um
in a sense that the timing it we can't
make decisions about timing of
investments
nor should we it should be the fund
managers that make that decision
so i don't think we need to get too het
up about that
you know i think i think the point is
the principle and do we want to
recommend a cabinet
but they that that we
we push i mean my feeling is we
recommend that
we we push the fund managers more to
the existing ones we have schroders and
the other three or four
to say um you know
can you filter your investment decisions
for fossil fuels so you if not eliminate
but you reduce
the the um investment in fossil fuels
and and if if they say no this is let's
take it or leave it
then we extigate other providers
other other managers that do have there
are loads out there
of um ethical managers that will apply
a filter um regarding fossil fuels and
on um on on their investments
um so that's that's the principle and
then
uh you know the fund managers will tell
us if if
oh no we can't put you know i mean
usually what we do in the pension fund
we did shift a load into a low-carbon
fund and they
they just we said we want to do it and
the fund manager said well the best way
to do it is phase it
over three over six months in three lots
so you're not you're not exposed to the
vagaries of the ups and downs of the
stock market
and and that's the way you do any
transition
um with with uh with investment funds
so i mean i i think a pr
i don't know whether we want to to put
it to a vote or
but that's my proposal that we that we
we
recommend that the fund managers we
recommend the cabinet
um urge fund managers to
um to apply a filter and if not we
we um we then look for
for different fund managers
catherine in your year john quickly then
yeah i mean i
i do essentially agree with that the the
um
whichever one it is that's actually um
offering a filtered
option instead i think the cabinet
should seriously consider
um shifting shifting that one
um if the capital losses are that we
have to
uh record are less than than um
than you know they are at the moment or
that they were when
we last looked well that's that's also
the good but i did
try and explain that that is essentially
not relevant
to the decision and i think others have
said that in in similar ways as well
and yes i entirely agree that
with robert that we should be um
telling all all our investment
managers in the in the various funds
we want this to have a higher priority
ask your
um you know tell your tell your
vp and all the rest of them they need to
stop investing in extracting more
you know the message from the science is
very clear leave it in the ground
and that applies whether we talk about
oil whether it's gas
coal pete all of them leave them in the
ground
is the only safe thing to do and we have
to
put that across so
thank you councillor matheson any other
comments or thoughts
catherine are we safe to send that sort
of message
um to cabinet or make a recommendation
today i'll have to call for a vote in a
moment i think
um if it's a reasonable motion i would
support it because i think we do need
to do something but that doesn't um
mean we whip money out of fee earning
things and put it somewhere a little bit
um
dicey it's got to be done well so um
your view pleased
as our section 151 officer yeah
just one thing i do just want to come
back on uh councillor matheson was
talking about the
you know the losses the book losses and
book losses do
become real when you sell the assets
so i know talking about cifco as well
they're currently book
losses but if we sold those cifco assets
that is a real loss
as with these fund investments it's on
it's on paper at the moment
but if we actually divest it then then
it becomes it becomes a real
loss um in terms of your discussion
yes you know i agree you know where
you've got to asking cabinet you know to
consider
you know pushing the fund managers seems
acceptable and then you know
what we do um i suppose i was just
wondering whether you want to put any
suggest any more parameters around that
you know
at what point um you know bearing in
mind that the capital loss that might
happen
whether you wanted to say what might be
acceptable you know is it five percent
ten percent you know twenty percent what
what you might consider to be acceptable
but also um initially you know bearing
in mind i hear what you're saying about
future funds these might take off
because that's where money will be going
in in future and the returns could
be a lot higher there will be an initial
loss as well in terms of the income
but again you know whether you want to
give any sort of
steer again on what that acceptable
position might be as well
so just a couple of other things to to
think about in terms of that
recommendation thank you catherine uh
yes i'm
very much mindful of what catherine says
although it's a book price
if you sell it at three quarters what
it's worth you've only got that money to
buy something else so it is a quite a
steep loss and we do need to bear that
in mind
if somebody's going to propose i'd like
something that all nine of us
could agree on with a reasonable time
frame
or it may just have to be judgment um
catherine sand well how much are we
prepared to lose well
i think probably it should just be down
to the judgment of our experts
at the time because it's not only what
you sell to lose it's what you might buy
to gain that's
um it's going to be a very very
difficult um
seesaw to judge so are you going to put
a proposal councillor madison
the chair uh you know something we can
build on
the yeah the the parameter that i would
want
want to to offer is is actually a
parameter about how much
um income we're prepared to forego
um because i've as i've you know
still maintain the the
the capital loss is is not actually
real because we will invest the money
again and
if it's invested fairly well then the
chances are it will go up just the same
way
that um the
the the current fund is is going up as
the market rises
uh it will float or what's the old thing
about the rising tide floats all the
ships and all the rest of it
um yeah so i you know i would i would
suggest that
as a as a proposal that we um
are willing to forego 25
of of our income
in order to get into um a better
mix of investments that's just
that's a parameter which people can
dispute and whatnot if you like but
i i really i can't i can't think of i
can't
focus on any specific capital loss
parameter because i don't think it
matters
you know obviously
[Music]
i'm not sure john i can support that i i
would imagine that
if you sell something that's going up
you need to buy something that's gone up
at the same amount so it's a straight
swap then
then the book price doesn't matter i
can't see any reason why we need to
incur a loss at all really
if we invest in something that's um
non-fossil fuel which has gone up
also at the similar amount to what our
current investment is and there's no
[Music]
loss
lost capital loss to lead suffer
if nothing if it doesn't change at all
then
we get rid of half of whatever then we
put 450
000 into this year's loss
a couple of years and then we declare it
so that you know it doesn't make any
difference
could i could i help out a bit or maybe
i don't know i hope i can help yes go
for it councillor lindsay
please yeah um so i think i think uh
the chairman was was asking why
you think there would be an income loss
you weren't asked
he wasn't asking about the capital thing
he was saying
why will it be an income loss if we
switch
the and enough and i i don't know
whether they are
i mean obviously when you change your
there's always a bit of an upfront cost
when you
swap your if you change your portfolio a
bit
you have to pay there's a penalty clause
and there's a bit of extra
cost for that
[Music]
but but on an ongoing basis
you seem to be implying about 25 percent
well
there will be a loss of income
acceptance current rates
you know um the officers at the
beginning the officer said
second issue the yield difference
between
the filtered and the unfiltered and at
the moment the fossil fuel companies are
paying out lots of dividends
so the the um you know the unfiltered
produces
a better return and i was saying that we
we should be prepared to forego
something in the short term
and i mean if if if council amoroson is
right and and
and i'm right then um in due course
the the the you know the the the more
forward-looking account
fund we'll we'll we'll earn more and we
and that loss will be eliminated but
on the moment i'm just saying that we
should be willing to forego
some income in order to do the right
thing
and yes i i'm optimistic that in the in
the medium term
it it's the you know it's the tesla
electric cars of this world investments
that are zooming up
um on the on the on the market and
lots of other you know energy storage
and these kinds of things
um are are going up yeah
so difficult but i mean
i think sorry we're getting a bit bogged
down here my feeling was
that we should um give the go-ahead i'm
not too worried about the book price
i am worried about the income that's the
difference you see i would like to swap
a fossil fuel investment for something
that's a bit greener with a similar
income
you know the book price is just a
straight swap on the book
and i'm not too sure you were
understanding that john it's the income
i'm concerned about
because we need it to survive these earn
about
close to half a million pounds a year
across baby mid suffolk and um
i don't want to see that diminished um
at all really
but certainly not much um council
ramblers said you did you just
hand up are you saying um
you you just want a general principle
and an idea of
the the money that we're or the
percentage that we're prepared to lose
but
you're not looking for specific advice
on where to put the money like that
we're going to leave that to the uh
the officers so so is it just a case of
agreeing between us
a figure you know um i think it we just
need to agree a steer to say look we
want you to do this but we don't want a
loss of income we'd like it swapped for
a similar fee
earning bond yeah and by what point do
we want to see actual gains
you know sorry and by what point do we
want to see
actual well what hope gains well if it's
a straight swap
earning three percent for something else
they're earning three percent then it is
it then becomes a straight swap from one
place to another doesn't which i think
is what catherine was saying also
plus in the nine months it takes to do
this the present pond may um
keep going up to a much better position
anyway
i just want to see a gradual movement
sensible without losing any
loss of income because um because we do
things with income like
biodiversity and plant trees and all
sorts of things
also so for me the um the gap has got to
be pretty narrow or
not exist we're saying whatever proposal
we put forward is provisional
then based on um we're sending us
a cabinet to get on with it in the best
way possible bearing in mind that
we can't afford to lose any money that's
what i'm looking for
yes i i totally agree with you we may
just
ask the cabinet the officers fund
managers just to give a steer
i'm totally against giving you know be
totally against
a reduction of 25 percent absolutely you
know against that
absolutely not nobody can give us and
i would only be prepared to support a
steer on this
and we can chase someone i would think
say look um
i think and on the time these take
we may commit winners on both fronts
that's what we've got to look to do
would you agree catherine that's fairly
sensible way forward
uh yes chair and i think you had the
earlier suggestion about
um asking cabinet to push the fund
managers about you know whether they
would filter i mean that that
that seemed you know a reasonable
proposition to to go into cabinet
and then depending on obviously what the
fund managers said as a result of that
then consider
you know whether at the appropriate
point you move move the funds elsewhere
and to report back to this committee i
think that would be sensible
or could i have a proposer and a second
uh maybe um
one from dave and one from robert or
one of the greens so so that we unified
and we can chase that afterwards i think
that's the way forward from here
right and you're willing to
fine okay all in favor show of hands on
this one
sorry i can't hit with your mask on
james
sorry can i just have that um read out
again please exactly what we're voting
on there because
yes we're sending a proposal to cabinet
um that we would like to see funds
diversified
to more green friendly that's not the
word that i'm looking for but i'm sure
somebody is writing it down
investments um and we we might be
willing to
take a small hit but no more than a
small hit when we're aiming for equal um
equal return i would think
i think what catherine said was um
that we pushed the fund managers to ask
for filtered
investment so they filter the
investments if they can
see if they can offer us filtered
investments in other words filtered for
fossil fuel
and then and then we take it from there
i think
we see what they say but but um
you know my feeling is if they can't we
should then
investigate other fund managers
well i think we've sent a clear message
and it will give us the right to push a
bit as well and ask for um
feedback um that would be my um
way of doing it and we may win in two
different directions
the fund may get worth more which will
buy more alternative funds
in the green market which will be good
and if things have changed a bit
nothing's going to happen for nine
months probably a year um
you know these things don't happen in
three months or even
six so as long as we're going in the
right direction from here
we could do quite well and change the um
direction of this council as well which
i'd be very happy with but
as i sit in the chair i don't want us to
take a big hit because
it will mean we do less for our
constituents and
biodiversity which is also um green
works in all ways
you had your hand up cancer amazon
i really want to get this away from
being sort of negatively let's just
we're saying that we want to divest but
let's let's think about
if we can put it to the cabinet let's
look at opportunities
you know and and in the in the new tech
that's that's that's now in development
and
there are real opportunities there so i
want that positive
vibe to be in the uh in the proposal as
well you know that it's not just about
let's avoid
things let's let's be proactive you know
completely in favor of that
um mandy have you written this down into
something that could be read out
[Music]
it's i'm sorry guys it's very difficult
to share and write and
get it all in together as well but i'm
doing my best here
um councillor norris you haven't spoken
today
are you generally happy with what's
being done here
i was just asking are you generally
happy with what's
being done here because you haven't
spoken yet today
i fell as i walked into the meeting
actually so i haven't been picking up
i'm sorry but my only comment while i
have the opportunity
please do highlight that of course
capital
valuations are a snapshot in time aren't
they yes
and these move up and down as we know in
the long term so it is a trend
really that we should be looking at
effectively and i think as regards
any reduction in
income i think it's difficult actually
to put a quantitative percentage figure
on any sort of reduction
without perhaps some further work
looking at
what are the viable realistic
alternative options for
investment i've accepted the report i
think it's a very good report
but i think we can go on from this now
it gives us
the situation it gives us a status quo
as it exists at the moment
and i think then we need to phrase the
recommendation that's put forward
more or less on the lines that have been
put into words yeah thank you councillor
norris
thank you mandy have i brought you a bit
of time
i think emily may um just want you
sorry emily yes
thank you chairman i've been writing as
you've all been talking and i hope i
might have crafted something that
reflects the the will of the committee
um and if
you are in agreement chair then i would
suggest that the the vote can just say
as read out by the monitoring officer so
that mandy doesn't have to furiously
type it into the system
and so the recommendation i'm suggesting
chair is
that the joint order and standards
committee recommends that the cabinet
pushes its fund managers to filter
investments
in respect of the esg considerations
looking for positive contributions to
tackling our carbon
reduction priorities and that the
cabinet considers withdrawing funds from
investors who do not adequately
adequately address these concerns the
joint audit
and standards committee recognises that
any decision to withdraw funds
should be balanced against financial
prudence
uh councillor casting i'm looking for a
proposal and a second and now and then
we'll go to the electronic vote
thank you mr chairman i think that's
actually
worked quite well for me because i've
been sitting here wondering whether i
can support
something along those lines and the
biggest thing for me
is the the vague
um sort of understanding of whether a
company's
good for the environment or bad for the
environment and
a fossil fuel company i don't think will
wake up one day and go oh there's no
more fossil fuel cars
we better shut the officers and board up
the windows
and i think potentially in the future
like
with green hydrogen it could easily be
these companies that are doing it
but if um if we're looking at our
investments
and looking at whether those companies
are actually prepared to do
that kind of work and move on and move
forward
like we want them to i can i can support
this and i think this is a good
recommendation
thank you angela mueller thank you yes i
too i'm happy with that proposal from
emily will be happy to support that
thank you so we have a proposal and a
second uh
thank you everybody it's been um it's
been good little difficult to share but
we are there
would you like to take us to the vote
mandy yes chair so
thank you to the monitoring officer for
um
so what i've put in the vote is just to
vote on the recommendation as read
out by the monitoring officer and
obviously that will all be minuted
so that vote is now in progress on
modern.gov
councillor lindsay thank you
yeah that's fine mandy would you like me
to
oh yeah you've done thank you
that's unanimously for chair
thank you um and thank you councillors
it's always good to have a united um
front i feel it gives us
more clout and we will follow up i
will as chair definitely uh item 10 the
forward plan
in front of you this is our work setup
it's
for um noting any any comments on
what we have to do any add-ons or things
we should be doing
please
everybody happy
next meeting 26th of july which
councillor muller will be chairing
which works well so far
okay we're all content with that yep
thank you very much does that need a
vote
mandy no that's just noted then
okay thank you very much
um everybody you didn't wish to comment
on that did you emily
no that's fine
that's the end of the meeting then apart
from signing the minutes
i think i may have several to sign is
that correct i
thought you were going to pounce well um
dave and i will lovely stay behind and
do the appropriate ones that will bring
us up
to date which will be good great to see
you all
stay safe and see you on
you